Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
Ahh!
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight, billionaire founder
of the Virgin Group,
Richard Branson, joins the Tank.
What I love
about "Shark Tank"
is everyday people
solving everyday problems.
If you know anyone that owns
an airline, let me know.
This is not a cheap business
to get into.
This is
a completely different business.
Last year was about $3 million.
Wow.
The only way
to figure this thing out
is to study people's DNA.
I'll make you an offer,
but I want you
to say yes or no
right now.
Well, we have a guest here.
Forget him.
Isn't that a great offer?
What would you offer
for two or three Sharks?
Uh, depends on the Sharks.
What?
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a product
created to solve a problem
the entrepreneur had
as a fighter‐jet mechanic.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name's Tom Burden.
I'm from the small farm town
of Celina, Ohio,
and I'm seeking $200,000
in exchange for 10%
of my company.
Sharks, let me ask you
a question.
Have you ever been inspired
by a really good idea
when doing maintenance
on a fighter‐jet machine gun?
Oh.
All the time.
Oh, yeah.
Every day.
Well, I have.
I'm an F‐16 weapons mechanic
in the United States Air Force,
and I encounter a problem
time and time again.
When working
on top of the aircraft,
I'm constantly trying
to keep my tools close
and my hardware organized.
Seems like a simple enough task,
but on the aircraft's
slick surface,
it is nearly impossible.
Would you believe me
if I told you that,
in general aviation,
to solve this problem,
mechanics are using anything
from rags, muffin trays,
and, my favorite,
urinal cakes.
Yes.
Hopefully clean urinal cakes.
Clearly, these products
just aren't cutting it.
To solve this problem,
I introduce to you the Grypmat.
It's a flexible,
nonslip tool tray
ensuring that your tools
and hardware
stay in place on any surface.
We currently have three sizes ‐‐
the small, medium, large ‐‐
all equipped with the ability
to hold tools
up to a 70‐degree angle.
Let me show you how it works.
The small's equipped
with six compartments
to keep your hardware
organized.
The medium
has two small compartments
and an open field
for hand tools.
And then the large
has four small compartments,
an open field for hand tools,
and then handles so you can
easily move your workstation.
Although the Grypmat
was born into aviation,
it can be found useful
in every field,
whether it's making hats
out of your garage,
building rockets,
assembling computers,
making jewelry,
or tinkering underneath
the hood of your car.
So, Sharks,
one question remains ‐‐
who here is ready to get a grip?
A Grypmat, that is.
Cuban: Do you have samples
for us to look at?
Yes.
And thank you
for your service.
‐Thank you.
‐Absolutely.
‐Yeah.
‐So, this is the medium.
The medium is actually
the most popular size.
Right.
So, if you notice,
on the medium and the large,
there's also
a measurement system.
Branson:
What I love about "Shark Tank"
is that everyday people
are solving everyday problems.
With Virgin Galactic in mind
and with our airlines in mind,
um, yeah,
this would be tremendous.
Our engineering teams,
they would welcome
something like this enormously.
You can make
an offer right now.
Richard, Richard ‐‐
If you know anyone
that owns an airline,
let me know, and we could ‐‐
we could ‐‐
Branson: Look, I tell you what,
we would definitely buy them.
So, the question is whether you
can make money as a business,
so...
Have you sold any yet?
Do you have
a business here yet?
Yes.
So, we've sold
roughly 10,000 units,
total of $400,000
in sales.
Oh.
And when did you
start selling?
We started selling, um,
roughly 10 months ago.
What was your net?
So, between $150,000
and $200,000,
which I've taken that and
reinvested it into inventory.
‐Wow.
‐Good for you. Good for you.
That's impressive.
‐That's great.
John: All right, where have
you been selling them?
Yeah. So, um, the big thing
has been, um, selling online.
Trade shows have been
very significant for us.
So far, I've gotten
a handful of, um, fighter jets,
and then, also,
I've sold to NASA.
We're specifying
in the aviation industry,
and we're about to grow
into the automotive industry.
Are you gonna go into retail
with ‐‐ with it at all?
That's something, honestly,
I need guidance on
of how to navigate with ‐‐
especially with the big‐box.
Um, it's my understanding,
they'll really push you around.
What's the application
for cars, though?
I'm underneath the car,
everything's flat.
Right, if you're working
underneath the hood of the car,
typically what you're doing
is you're scattering your tools
all over the engine.
So your tools are typically,
like, black or silver,
which just blend in
to the engine.
So, like, the key thing
within the product
is getting the user in the habit
of putting the tools
into the tray,
so building that habit.
Okay. So, what do you
sell them for at retail,
what's your cost?
Yeah.
So, retail,
the small is $29.99.
The medium is $44.99.
‐Wow.
The large is $69.99.
Landed cost
is roughly 25% of that.
Is this silicone?
It's a silicone‐polymer mix.
Silicone goes to
500 degrees.
Correct.
Let's say on an engine
or if it's hot,
that's not gonna melt.
Correct.
Silicone
goes to 500 degrees?
‐It does.
‐You're smart, lady.
You're smart.
[ Laughter ]
So, aren't there other silicone
trays out there, or no?
No, basically, the hot thing
that's been selling is just ‐‐
it's a sheet of material.
So, t‐the big thing
is having the lip
so things can't, like,
roll down.
Have you applied to any ‐‐
for any patents or anything?
Yes, right now, we have
a‐a utility patent pending.
So, how much have you
invested so far?
So, personal money,
about $40,000,
and then also raised
about $150,000
through grants and doing
business competitions.
You are incredible,
my friend.
So, Tom,
what ‐‐ what's the next step?
My vision for the company is to
keep inv‐inventing new products.
Um, that's something
that I see a lot
that's a big problem
within the startup community
is that they're not
innovative people.
It's people
with an innovative idea.
They have one good idea,
and they can't make 2.0,
they can't shock the world
with the next generation.
So, what is your 2.0?
I want to have more products
that integrate with the Grypmat,
things that would attach
to the Grypmat,
if it's a flashlight,
a magnet,
or if it's, you know,
something with a lid.
If you're gonna be the chief
innovation officer, right,
Yes.
...who's gonna run
the company?
Uh, that's where
I'm slowly building a team.
Okay. So your challenge appears
to be back office,
putting together
a sales force, right?
Right.
Having an organization
already in place...
Right.
...so you can focus on...
Innovation.
...innovation
while somebody else
handles all the nuts and bolts
of the business.
Yes.
I'm curious about you.
You said that you grew up
in a small town in Ohio.
Yes.
Can you tell us
about yourself?
Growing up, I always
wanted to be an inventor.
Came time to go to college,
my parents told me
that they weren't going to
pay for my college,
so, um, to call their bluff,
I told them
I was gonna join the military.
Turns out they weren't bluffing,
and...
[ Laughter ]
...so now I've been in the
service for eight years now.
What are you gonna do
with the $200,000?
I'm going to reinvest it
into more inventory
so we can beef up our ‐‐
our volume
so we can get the price down
per piece.
All right, Tom, listen,
I see a different application.
I think there's something else
here I think this is good for.
Infants I think this is good
for...
For infants?
...senior living, with dexterity
issues, in hospitals.
Barbie.
Daymond, you can't
put your baby in this.
For Barbie's shoes?
Well, trust me ‐‐
babies like to
throw things
across the room, right?
Or ‐‐ Or even in hospital beds,
right?
You know, the ‐‐ the tray
can easily, um, slide off.
So are there other areas that
you've tried to sell at all?
So, had a lot of interest in,
like, gunsmiths,
medical is
a really big one.
Yeah.
I'm from Britain.
What ‐‐ What's a gun?
[ Laughter ]
I think this can have
a lot of applications.
I want to take it over to my
friends over at Cox Automotive
and also going to
the areas I talked about.
So I'm gonna offer you, uh,
$200,000 for 25%.
Okay.
Um, well, we have a guest.
Forget him.
Isn't that a great offer?
Uh...I think I asked for 10%,
but we'll see. We'll see.
W‐What's the market that you
think you just have to be in,
that's just
gonna propel you?
To ‐‐ To me, aviation,
it's easy kills all day.
I think aviation
is so overrated.
I have a deal on the table
for you here.
Look, I have three planes,
right?
I have my own little airline
that I actually own 100% of...
Ooh! "I have three planes!"
Ooh!
...as opposed to
just having investors.
Greiner: I'm sure Richard
has his own planes.
Excuse me,
billionaires,
I have $200,000
on the table for 25%.
I'll...
All right, every time,
I've got to prove my love!
I got $200,000 for 20%.
20%? We're getting closer.
What? You went to 20%?
Herjavec: Closer, closer.
I went to 20% 'cause I don't
have time for you guys.
So, I'll be honest
with you guys ‐‐
my mission here
is to get as many Sharks
to take a bite out of
Grypmat today as possible.
Now,
if you want multiple Sharks,
you realize you'll have to
give up more equity,
'cause it's really not worth 5%
if we split it two ways.
‐Correct.
‐Okay.
What would you offer
for two or three Sharks?
Uh, depends on the Sharks.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Tom has one offer on the table
from Daymond
for his silicone tray,
Grypmat.
So, I'll be honest
with you guys ‐‐
my mission here
is to get as many Sharks
to take a bite out of
Grypmat today as possible.
What would you offer
for two or three Sharks?
Uh, depends on the Sharks.
♪♪
Well, tell us
what Sharks you want.
So far, there's only one offer.
Only one person believes in you.
Yeah, I'm not ‐‐
Tom, I'm not like Daymond.
I'm not gonna
bet against myself.
Just tell us
what Sharks you want.
Well, obviously,
we have a Shark
that has some experience within
the aviation and space industry.
Branson: Look,
I think you're fantastic.
I think you should concentrate
on what you're good at,
which is, um,
developing new products
and ‐‐ and the product line.
I'd be delighted if
another Shark would
come with me on this.
I have an idea, Richard.
Yeah.
I mean, you know
a lot about airplanes,
I know a lot about cars.
I see it as a big
automotive‐industry product.
But I'm gonna want
more equity,
but I also think
we're gonna need more cash.
What about $200,000
for 20% each,
for a total offer
of $400,000 for 40%?
♪♪
Branson: Yeah, I don't think
Tom is interested
in giving up
so much equity,
so I'll offer $200,000
at 15%.
‐15%?
‐15%?!
I'll do $200,000
at 15%.
John: Every time,
I got to prove my love.
$200,000, 15%.
♪♪
Cuban: Tom, here's what I see.
The product sells itself.
Unlike most entrepreneurs, you
have no fear of how it'll sell.
Correct?
Yes.
What you're missing
is infrastructure.
Corporately, you don't have
a sales guy.
Right.
The more you have to
deal with all that,
the less time you have
to do everything else.
John: Tom,
are you gonna concentrate
on the business as ‐‐ as well
as you're concentrating
on these three offers
you have on the table?
Now you're talking to somebody
that does not have an offer yet.
Well, 'cause you keep
on interrupting.
You have three offers
for $200,000 for 15%
by each Shark ‐‐ Daymond,
Richard, and Robert.
Well, let me ‐‐ let me tell you
what our offer is,
and I'll let you decide.
Lori and I together, we're gonna
offer $200,000 for 20%,
but here's the other part.
We'll take over everything.
Okay.
We'll have inventory systems,
custom delivery systems for you,
so wherever you need to ship it,
take over the whole thing.
We'll charge you our costs,
basically...
Yes.
...'cause you'd have to
pay that anyways.
Okay.
Greiner: What I'll bring
to the table is,
I already am in
and have great relationships
with Home Depot,
Lowe's, Ace, True Value...
Yep, we both do.
...all of that ‐‐
and QVC,
and anywhere else that I think
we can get this into.
I've also been in Pep Boys
with my Drop Stop.
What was your offer?
$200,000 for 20%.
Okay.
♪♪
It's all very well
you're saying
that you're gonna help him
by finding people to do things,
but you're gonna charge him
back at cost,
so he, you know ‐‐
he might as well just ‐‐
No, we already have
the people to do those things.
We've got people globally,
as well,
that are gonna be
very happy to help.
Would you do 30%
at $360,000?
What?
30% ‐‐ 1, 2, 3 ‐‐
for $360,000?
I would ‐‐
I would do that.
‐Deal.
‐Done!
[ Laughing ] Wow.
That was pretty cool.
You're a smart kid.
[ Chuckles ]
Thank you, sir.
Great. I'll give you a hug.
‐Yeah, thank you.
‐Well done. See ya.
Oh! [ Laughs ]
I feel like getting Richard,
Mark, and Lori
is verification that I am
supposed to be an inventor,
and I feel like I am doing
what I'm put on Earth to do.
Narrator: In season 5,
Jamie Siminoff pitched Doorbot,
a smart‐video doorbell
and left without a deal.
Let's see what he's up to now.
Siminoff: Walking away
from the Sharks
was one of the hardest things
that's ever happened to me.
But as any entrepreneur,
no matter what you face,
you have to keep going.
After "Shark Tank," we started
selling Doorbots like crazy,
and that drove sales to
$3 million within the year.
As the business grew, we didn't
want to be just one product,
and so we built a whole line
of home‐security solutions
and rebranded it as Ring.
And we were able
to get in huge retailers
like Home Depot, Target,
and Best Buy.
And that's when Richard Branson
came knocking on our door.
Richard was so impressed
with Ring
that he reached out and invested
for 5% of the business.
Branson: So, great new
Ring products.
Branson:
I couldn't quite work out why
the Sharks turned him down.
I mean, it just seemed to be
a wonderful idea.
Now I think the latest round's
gonna be close to
a billion dollars.
Not only does this change
the way home security's done,
but it's also
really affordable.
Siminoff: We're now launching
Ring Protect,
which is our
indoor alarm system,
which works with
an outdoor ring of security
to help prevent crime
before it happens.
And those Sharks
that turned you down,
sorry, Mark, sorry, Sharks.
[ Laughs ]
I'm excited
to be here today.
We're about to send out
our first Ring Protect
to our first neighbor.
I always hoped
that we'd be able
to do something impactful
with our product.
I never thought
it'd be as big as this.
It's now been four years
since "Shark Tank,"
and the business
is now valued at $1 billion.
Today, we're over 1,300 people,
10 core products, 16,000 stores.
I think Ring is proof
that entrepreneurship
is still alive and well
in America.
All it took was one idea,
perseverance, and execution,
and now today, we have
a billion‐dollar company.
All: Ring!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a business
created to aid
and optimize medical research.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Olivier Noel.
I'm from Queens, New York.
Yeah.
My company is DNAsimple,
and I'm seeking $100,000
in exchange for 12.5%
of the company.
Sharks, experts are saying that
we are due for a new pandemic,
a catastrophic disease
that can devastate humanity.
And that's why
medical research
is even more important
than ever,
and that's where we come in.
DNAsimple is looking to make
genetic research
happen 10 times faster
so that cures to diseases
can be found 10 times faster.
And my company
is literally paying you
for your saliva sample.
It's all anonymous, and it
happens in four easy steps.
Number one,
you tell me about yourself
in two minutes
on our DNAsimple website.
Number two, we match you
to a research study
that's looking for
people like you.
Number three,
we ship you this little tube
to your house
with a prepaid stamp.
And number four, we give you $50
after you've returned
the sample back to us.
And you can do this
as many times as you can.
You heard correctly ‐‐
we're paying you
for spitting in a tube.
Normally,
it's an extremely expensive
and very long process
for researchers
to get enough samples
for studies,
and our company is basically
making it simple.
We pay you for your spit,
researchers get
the samples they need,
and we get paid
for making it all happen.
It's a win‐win for everybody.
Now, Sharks, who's ready
to join me in saving mankind?
I will come around and show you
what the kits look like.
Great.
Here's one for you.
Thanks, Olivier.
Let me give Lori hers.
Such a gentleman.
Thank you, Robert.
‐You're welcome, Lori.
‐Thank you, sir.
Hopefully, you do match
a study and get your $50.
Thank you very much.
You said that you just
spit into the tube,
send it back to you,
you will pay that person $50,
and they can do it
as often as they want?
If they get matched for a study.
Correct.
For example, if there are
10 researchers across the U. S.
that are looking for...
Female, this and that...
...someone age 20 to 45, that
fit in a particular profile.
No, get it right ‐‐
20 to 25.
[ Laughs ]
In your case, 20 to 25.
Yes.
And so every time you do match,
you get a notification
that you can participate
to the study, and then
we send you a kit,
and every time,
you can get that $50.
So, Olivier, I only get $50
if you can match me to a study.
I will send this to you
after you've matched the study.
Okay. So, how much
are they paying you?
Typically, it would go around
$155 per sample.
So the research companies
are paying you $155.
You're paying $50 of that
right off the top...
Yes.
...for the sample.
Correct.
Any other cost to you?
So you make $100 ‐‐
So, the kit. So, we have ‐‐
We're making the kits in‐house.
And what's it cost you
to make each one?
$12.50.
So, people
are answering online,
and they're telling you
about themselves,
and you're trusting that that
information is accurate, right?
How do you vet
that it is?
Okay.
So, for example, if I'm giving
this to a cancer researcher,
I could be a drug addict...
Yeah.
...which is gonna completely
skew the test.
Correct.
Basically,
I leave that to the researcher
to decide
what is that one burden of proof
that the person has to submit
to be qualified.
They only upload
a little bit,
and then you reach out to them
according to the study and say,
"Do you have more proof?"
right?
Exactly. Exactly.
You put the information
that the researchers will use.
Cuban: Oh.
Well, let me ask you
more about yourself.
So, where ‐‐ where
in Queens are you from?
So, I lived in Flushing, uh,
for a little bit.
Sure, sure.
I'm actually from Haiti,
so I‐I grew up in Haiti.
But in Haiti,
we got the earthquake,
so after high school,
I moved to New York
because I had
a lot of family there,
and that's where
opportunities took me.
And worked my butt off.
I worked up to five jobs
in college.
Majoring in chemistry
and biochemistry
and graduated with honors
in biomedical science research.
What school?
At Queens College.
I tutored French, Spanish,
math, chemistry,
and biology
to private students.
I was selling bags
and ‐‐ and watches at Fossil.
And I was working, also,
next door,
selling jeans and shirts
at American Eagle.
Wow.
So I got a full scholarship
to go to Penn State
for both an MD and a PhD.
Can I make a nonpolitical
comment here?
Yeah.
You're ‐‐ You're
the exact reason why America
should open up to immigrants,
I mean, 'cause
what a wonderful example
you are,
to come from Haiti
and do such great work.
But why do you think
there's gonna be a pandemic?
What we've realized
in the past decade or so
is that there are subtypes
of the same disease
that's directly based
off your genes in you DNA.
So the only way
to figure this thing out
is to study people's DNA.
Do you have a database,
like you go through hospitals
and research centers,
who know who needs this DNA?
Yes. So,
the researchers are there.
Are you going out to them,
or are they coming to you?
‐Both, both.
‐Okay.
Herjavec:
But give me an example.
How much money
do they typically give you?
Do they need 10 samples?
A typical study
at an academic institution
would need 30,000 samples,
up to 100,000 samples.
Wow.
But the range is extremely wide.
You could use a small study
where you need 25 samples.
Have you sold any so far?
Yes, we have.
We've matched over 500.
We've sold for $30,000.
And how are you
sourcing your subjects?
The most effective so far
has been social media.
How'd you get the trust
for your company?
It ‐‐ It was a little tougher
at the beginning.
Now that we've had
significant press this year ‐‐
I made the Forbes list
30 Under 30 in science.
Ah!
Congratulations.
Yeah,
that's where I saw you.
Thank you.
And so we've been everywhere.
So now it's more like
we need the machine
to get more of a presence
on social media.
I used to sell my blood
all the time.
That was the only way
I could afford ‐‐
‐It's less invasive.
‐Yeah.
But this is just
a new‐age version of that.
‐Yes.
‐It's amazing.
Where's the competitive
advantage, Olivier?
Why is your company worth
$1 million today?
Well,
I've worked in the field,
so I understand
exactly what researchers want
and what can pass
and what will not pass.
I literally did this
kind of research for my PhD.
So I think that's
a competitive advantage there.
But, obviously, if we get
one of you Sharks on board,
that's a significant advantage.
What do you
really need the money for?
Do you need entry into
larger researcher facilities?
Do you need ‐‐
Yes.
Until I have 100,000 people
in my database,
I can't go to Pfizer
and say, "I want to help you
lead that next big research
you're gonna do."
Some researchers,
in a five‐year grant,
you spend three to four years
to recruit people.
Wow.
Literally,
there are studies that die,
because let's say
you're doing a study
where you'd need a
thousand blacks or Hispanics,
and I'm in
Hershey, Pennsylvania.
No offense ‐‐
it would take about
a hundred years to get
those people, right?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, less than 5% of clinical
trials have minorities in them.
Some people are hard to find,
and so this idea,
that's our
competitive advantage.
So, look, I've just sat here
listening for ‐‐ for a change
and not really contributed,
but having listened,
I think it's
really interesting.
I'm incredibly impressed
with you and your drive.
I'll offer you
$100,000 for 25%.
Cuban:
I'll make you an offer,
but I want you to say
yes or no right now, okay?
I'll give you $200,000
for 20%.
♪♪
Mark, is it ‐‐ is it okay
if I listen to a couple offers?
I‐I really appreciate
that offer.
If you want to do business with
me, and if not, I understand.
You have two offers
on the table.
Would you be willing to decrease
a little bit in equity...
and go 15%?
♪♪
Sure. Yeah.
Deal?
‐Deal.
‐Done.
Herjavec: Oh. Snatched it
right from Richard.
‐Congratulations.
‐I love the idea, man.
We'll make it.
We'll kill it.
‐I can't believe it.
‐We'll change the world.
I'll give you a hug, as well.
Hold on.
[ Laughter ]
I'll still take it.
Do I get a hug?
No. Go on.
Congrats.
Noel:
So, I was this little kid, 18
years old, coming from Haiti
with no money and no directions
and no plans.
And now I'm striking a deal
with a Shark.
Um, this is the American dream.
Narrator: Next up is
a high‐tech solution
that tackles
a common household chore.
♪♪
I'm Justin Crandall.
And I'm Bart Lomont.
We're from Dallas, Texas.
Cuban: What?!
Go, Dallas!
And we're seeking $500,000
for 5% of our company...
This better be good!
...Robin.
[ Laughter ]
Dang good.
So, every single year,
Americans spend $70 billion
on lawn‐care services that are
star‐‐ stuck in the Dark Ages.
Landscapers are
notoriously unreliable,
and they use dirty,
gas‐powered mowers
that are
destroying the planet.
In the 21st century,
when I can get
a battery‐powered car
that can drive itself,
why in the world is my lawn
still being mowed
by a guy
pushing a gas mower ‐‐ Sorry ‐‐
that is pushing
a gas mower
that emits more pollution
than 11 cars.
There has to be
a better way.
There is a better way.
Sharks, let me introduce you
to the future of lawn care.
Robin has launched
the world's very first
robotic
lawn‐mowing service.
‐Is it cutting now?
‐It's cutting.
‐It mulches it up?
‐It's only cutting
a little tiny
piece of grass each time,
so it goes out and mows
a little bit every single day.
Right.
And the clippings actually fall
down and act as fertilizer,
so you need about 25%
less fertilizer for your lawn.
This thing has a wire that's
buried around the perimeter.
That's how it knows
where the edge of the yard is.
This is one of the machines
that our crews use
in order to do
the installation of the wire.
Herjavec: Oh.
Oh, so you're putting the wire
in like a dog fence.
Yep.
So ‐‐ So, the first part of it
is, somebody comes in,
installs a wire
all the way around.
Yeah.
I assume there's
a sensor on the robot.
It goes to the wire,
and then it stops.
That's right.
We're taking proven
robotic mower technology
from Europe
and combining it
with high‐quality, human crews
to deliver a more reliable
and environmentally friendly
lawn‐care solution.
We have just begun
revolutionizing lawn care,
and we need one of you
on our side.
So, Sharks,
who's ready to cut a deal?
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Right.
Where does the robot go
to plug itself in?
So, every robot has
its own docking station.
It follows its wire,
it goes home.
So there you can see it
backing off.
It's heading out
for a day of work.
And then, at the end of the day,
it goes and finds itself home.
He's so cute.
You guys aren't
selling the robot.
No.
Nope.
‐You buy the robot from Europe.
‐Correct.
And you're selling
the service around it.
Exactly.
Much like homeowners already pay
a landscaping service.
There are over
a million of these
installed in Europe
right now...
‐Seriously?
‐Are they services?
...and in the United States,
it's less than 10,000.
In ‐‐ In Europe, though,
is it a service,
or are there
individuals owning them?
No.
Robin is launching the world's
first ever robotic lawn service.
What does one cost?
So, this one right here
costs about $1,800 to $1,900,
if you were a consumer,
to go out and buy it yourself.
Wow.
One thing that's really
important is that
we're charging you
$17 a week.
‐$17 a week.
‐$17 a week for mowing only.
‐That's very cheap.
‐How does it work?
So, you would call us or you
could just go to our website.
There's three plans ‐‐ there's
$17 a week for just mowing,
if you want regular edging
and trimming,
that's $25 a week,
and if you want weeding,
shrub trimming, the whole deal,
it's $37 a week.
‐That's all automated?
‐Those pieces are not automated.
We have crews
that actually go out
and do the edging
and all the other work.
Got it.
That's what I wanted to know.
And we should mention
the history of Robin,
we started the company
a little over two years ago
as more of a "Uber for lawn
care" type of business.
We've built it
to where we do
10,000 jobs a month
and about $400,000 a month
in sales
with that business.
John: Wait a minute.
You have a current business that
uses traditional lawnmowers,
and it's like Uber ‐‐
"Hey, need my lawn cut,"
boom, right?
Yeah.
How much are you doing
on that business, annually?
So, we are just under
a $5 million run rate
on the revenue side.
‐Okay.
‐Wow.
And we do about 10,000 jobs
a month in Houston,
Austin, and Dallas.
Okay. So this investment is in
that entire business, correct?
It's the whole thing.
Correct.
Okay. So you know what?
You don't look crazy now.
You look great.
Our goal is to convert
all of our customers
into robot customers.
It's more environmentally
friendly,
and, frankly,
it's better margin.
But the problem
isn't the margin.
The problem is
the capital cost, right?
What's it cost per customer?
So ‐‐ Yeah ‐‐ So, the
manufacturers are very motivated
to move this
into the U. S.
We have an agreement in which
we pay nothing up front,
we install the robot,
we charge you,
the customer,
for the first month,
we still don't pay
the manufacturer.
And then,
the next month,
we pay them $45 a month as
a lease model on the mower.
Isn't their grand incentive
to be that
they really want to sell them
to people here in America?
Crandall: They would love to
sell them to Americans,
but you sell them this robot,
great.
Now they look out there
and go,
"Okay. Now I'm going out
to do the edging,
and I'm gonna do the shrub
trimming and the weeding?"
And if you tried to hire
that same landscaper,
he's not gonna give you
a discount
just 'cause
he's not doing the mowing.
What's your own
personal background?
So, I grew up on a grain farm
in Indiana.
I enlisted in the military
shortly after 9/11.
I was studying agriculture.
I knew after those events
I had to do something.
I wanted
to serve my country.
‐Thank you for your service.
‐Thank you.
It was the greatest honor
of ‐‐ of my life.
I was an operations
and logistics officer.
That's always been, uh,
you know, my interest.
So you're a logistics guy.
Correct.
That's your background.
The operations side,
and that's what I do, you know,
for Robin there. I like ‐‐
Super important for this
business.
Yeah.
Justin,
what ‐‐ what's your background?
So, I grew up in a small town
called Dowagiac, Michigan,
parents a couple teachers.
All my aunts and uncles
were teachers.
I think I'm the black sheep
'cause I went into business,
but that was where
my passion was.
Got my MBA at Harvard, and I
moved down to Austin in 2005,
joined some startups
down there,
and then ran sales for another
e‐commerce‐related business
from about half a million
to $15 million in revenue
over three years.
You're an online guy.
Yep. I met Bart through
a mutual friend of ours,
and we started talking
about this lawn‐care idea.
I was like, "This is just
too ‐‐ too good to pass up."
How much money have you raised,
and how big is the team?
So, we've raised
just over $3 million,
and we have 10 full‐time
team members right now,
and then we have about
80 crews that we contract with.
What were
your sales last year?
Last year was about
$3 million.
Cuban:
What was your profit or loss?
We ‐‐ So, we have lost,
'cause we were spending
very aggressively
to grow.
‐Okay.
‐How much did you lose?
Uh, last year was just over
a million we invested.
Ooh.
What's your burn rate right now,
monthly burn rate right now?
So, we're right about
$100,000 a month.
Does that break even yet,
or did that ‐‐
How much is that losing?
So, we can break even
anytime we want.
All we have to do is stop
investing in acquisition.
This is not a cheap business
to get into.
This is an expensive business
‐I'll note that, too, every ‐‐
‐It is, though.
That's the problem.
But that's the barrier
to entrance.
Greiner: See, for me,
I'm a product person.
I look at this,
and I think,
"This is a consumer product
play more than a service."
Because of those reasons,
I'm concerned that
that will happen quicker
than I will see
a return on my investment.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Well, thank you.
Cuban: You guys, I think it's ‐‐
it's a winner.
I just think
it's such a long horizon,
in terms of getting
a return on investment,
and you're gonna have to
raise so much more money
in order to scale.
Those are the challenges, and
so, for those reasons, I'm out.
Branson:
I love what you're doing.
I think these machines
are ‐‐ are brilliant,
but I can't get close to
the $10 million valuation.
For that reason,
sadly, I'm out.
Herjavec: Yeah, you know,
all of the businesses
I drive down the street,
I see all the independent
little ma‐and‐pa garden people,
and I always wonder,
"Why hasn't somebody
consolidated that business?"
And to your credit,
in two years,
to get to $3 million in sales ‐‐
I mean, that's fantastic.
You're losing a million dollars
in order to get there,
and ‐‐ and I get it, but there's
got to be that tipping point.
I need to see it going,
"Boom!"
Don't know if I see it.
I'm out.
Yeah, you know,
when you first came out
with the 5% and all that crap,
I wanted to hammer you.
[ Both laugh ]
But then you started talking
about service to our country,
you know,
the rest of your family
is our most
underappreciated commodity,
which are teachers.
But on the other side,
just to lose
a million dollars a year,
as you're reinvesting ‐‐
So, which side are you on,
Daymond?
Huh?
Which side are you on?
I'm on the outside
of the fence. I'm out.
Congratulations on
what you've accomplished.
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you.
Greiner: Thank you.
Crandall: It's a billion‐dollar
market in Europe.
It will be
a billion‐dollar market
in the U. S.
with us driving it.
Two or three years from now,
they're gonna say,
"Dang! Why did I
pass on Robin?"
Mark, can you
make sense of this?
Where does the Ubers
and the Twitters of the world,
why do they keep
raising money?
K‐Keep getting more customers.
Just customer acquisition?
Because there's the point
where you win, right?
Amazon's the best
example of that,
but Amazon was losing money
up until last year.
Yeah, you know,
for years and years and years.
Cuban:
They're the ultimate startup.
If the company has
enough upside, then you say,
"You know what? Go for it.
I'll keep on giving you money."
Vir‐Virgin Galactic,
you know,
we've invested over a billion
dollars now without any income.
I've got a company
that does metallic 3‐D printing
with this unique formula.
He doesn't know it yet,
but he's gonna make his rockets
using this technology and it ‐‐
We ‐‐ We al‐‐
We already are.
Maybe not that specific one,
but we already are.
Yeah.
I mean, it'll be this one.
[ Laughter ]
Narrator: Next up is a way
to engage and inspire girls
to get into coding.
♪♪
Hi. My name is
Sharmi Albrechtsen.
I'm from Bethesda, Maryland,
and I'm asking $200,000 for 5%
of my company, SmartGurlz.
Sharks, we can all agree
that the latest robots
and drones are super cool,
but let's face it ‐‐
it's a boys' market,
and it's not
of interest to girls.
In addition, in the U. S.,
we have a major shortage
of engineers
in a male‐dominated workforce.
So how do we encourage
more girls into science,
technology, engineering,
and math?
We show them
how fun technology can be
by integrating it into the toys
they already play with.
I would like to introduce you
to SmartGurlz Siggy,
the world's first
coding robot for girls.
♪♪
Hi, guys.
[ Laughter ]
‐Hello.
‐Super cute!
Herjavec: Oh, wow,
it does a wheelie.
So, SmartGurlz Siggy
is a self‐balancing hoverboard
that carries
any 11‐inch fashion doll.
You can connect with it
with any smart device,
including phone and tablet.
Using our SugarCoded
proprietary app,
you can start coding
with the touch of a button.
Today, our SmartGurlz are gonna
show us a dance they coded
using our SugarCoded app.
♪♪
[ Chuckling ]
♪ Me, me, me, me and my girls ♪
♪ Takin' on the world ♪
♪ Make it spin, make it swirl ♪
♪ We can take over the world ♪
♪ It's been seven days,
we've been waitin' ♪
♪ But it's magical
in every way ♪
♪ Me and my girls gonna rip up
the town, the house down ♪
♪ They won't know
what happened ♪
♪ We're solo ♪
♪ If we're gonna... ♪
Whoo!
That was amazing, girls.
‐Good job, girls.
‐Good job.
‐Great job.
So, Sharks, who's gonna join me
and make all girls SmartGurlz?
Can I come?
So, if you want to come on up,
we'll show you how to code.
So, how does it work?
And as I mentioned,
Siggy carries
any 11‐inch fashion doll,
so we made you
a Richard Branson doll.
Here you go.
And you actually all ‐‐
And ‐‐ And ‐‐
We have "Shark Tank" dolls
for all of you.
Shall we give some samples
to the Sharks?
If I may say,
it's very flattering.
It looks about
20 years younger, so...
It's fantastic.
Ooh! I like this.
Look how buff I look.
‐Oh, look at Robert.
‐Yes.
I look like Matt Damon.
[ Laughs ]
Wow, Lori,
you look amazing.
Albrechtsen: That's you,
and ‐‐ and we put in you
in a gorgeous velvet suit.
‐I like her!
Nice!
That's me with hair.
[ Laughs ]
So, Sharmi, the Siggy is the
Segway‐like vehicle.
‐Exactly.
‐This is cool.
Okay.
We're doing puzzle 1,
and it says to move
50 centimeters forward
at 25% speed,
so you are going to
change the speed
by tapping right here to 25.
Yep.
And next change the amount of
centimeters from 25 to 50.
50.
And now you are going to
drag and drop the codes ‐‐
first, the speed.
Okay.
And next we're going to
"drive on floor"
to see if we got it right.
And now you know how to code.
[ Laughs ]
‐Yay! You did it!
‐Yay!
You're such a geek, Richard.
You're ‐‐ You're great teachers.
Thank you.
‐How old are you?
‐I'm 10.
‐You're 10. And you?
‐I'm 9.
And do you find it easy
or hard to do?
‐It's easy.
Sometimes for a beginner,
you can find it hard,
but when you get the hang of it,
it's pretty easy.
Herjavec:
To what degree can they ‐‐
If they get more advanced,
can they actually
enter the commands?
Yeah. We've actually
allowed for kids to also see
the code that they've made,
so you can see
the JavaScript you created.
So it's basically
learning your ABCs
before you start,
you know, writing novels.
How did you
come up with this idea?
My daughter was
struggling in math.
I was just like,
"What can I do?"
And then
I walked into her room,
and I ‐‐ I saw this, like,
line of dolls, and I thought,
"Can I connect robots
and dolls together
and make something
that's more inspiring for her?"
And that's how
SmartGurlz was created.
‐How long ago was that?
‐That was two years ago.
And what was your
next step to do that?
Okay. So, making something
self‐balancing
is very difficult.
That's why you had to get it
moving first, yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
And we spent almost a year
doing the mathematics on this.
And our very significant
e‐learning platform app,
SugarCoded,
is very special in the sense
that we put girls
in the center.
It's very story‐based.
And did you release this onto
the market yet?
We've only been on the market
for less than six months.
Okay.
And we've done $250,000
worth of sales
in that really short
period of time.
‐Wow.
‐Nice.
How did you get your sales?
So, um, the first thing
that I did was actually,
I went to the World's Toy Fair
with six prototypes.
I walked away with 300 names
of different companies
who were interested
in the product, and I thought,
"You know what? This is gonna ‐‐
This is gonna be big."
So then I started to
talk to some of them,
and I was able to actually get
some distributor agreements,
and that helped me
raise the funds.
So, the $250,000
is from one distributor,
a couple
of distributors?
It's for distributors,
also direct from retail,
also from Amazon.
So, where is it now, Sharmi?
Where can I see the ‐‐
It's available
online on our website.
What does it sell for?
I don't think we ever asked you.
Yeah, so it sells for
$79.99.
And what does it cost you
to make it?
‐About $18, landed.
‐Okay. Wow. That's great.
Let us know why you think
the company's worth
$4 million at this point.
One of the things
is how difficult it is
to do
the balancing algorithm.
And it makes it very special.
We could actually license or
sell the balancing algorithm.
It's very unique.
I tell you, that self‐balancing
thing is cool.
Doesn't it look like Richard
just met Lori, like...
[ Laughter ]
"Hey! You want some tea?"
Is this a patent on this?
We have a provisional patent
on our product.
I think this is valuable,
because out of the young ladies
that do go into engineering,
70% end up dropping out
of engineering
because they don't have other
females that they can relate to.
Yeah, exactly.
And I think if you get them
in early enough,
they will have
more females.
I'm interested
in licensing this thing out,
but you're asking a lot.
I would have to give you
the $200,000...
...for 30%.
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Daymond is interested
in SmartGurlz,
an engineering toy
geared towards girls,
but he wants a much bigger stake
of the company
than the 5%
Sharmi came in offering.
I would have to give you
the $200,000 for 30%.
Okay. Well, that's ‐‐
that's a lot.
Herjavec: Um, you know,
been in the toy business.
The Barbie doll, the 800‐pound
gorilla in that business,
sales have declined
the last couple of years.
But they're still ‐‐
I mean, one is sold
every three seconds, so...
There's nothing
to connect with them.
I applaud ‐‐ I applaud
what you're doing,
but the incarnation
of that idea is this doll.
And I think it's ‐‐
it's tough.
It's a tough,
tough business to be in.
Um...
Yeah, I don't want to
go back into it.
I'm out.
Greiner:
Let me tell you what I think.
I did a deal with Robert
that was a doll
that had imperfections ‐‐
cellulite and one eye
that's crooked
and, you know, all these things,
like normal people.
What happened is
that Barbie came out
with the exact same thing ‐‐
kind of crushed us.
I mean, this is
a completely different business.
If you go to the toy store
today, in the robotics section,
there is not one toy that's
specifically aimed at girls.
Such a smart idea,
but I really think
that Daymond's licensing offer
is the smartest thing,
'cause he's expert at that.
I have to be out.
It's so great
when you're learning things
and you don't know
you're learning things.
I mean, you're just playing.
Yeah, exactly.
Obviously, all of us would love
our kids to ‐‐ to learn to code,
and I love
what you're doing.
I think it's ‐‐
it's great.
But I don't think
I can add enough value
to your business to invest.
So, sadly, I'm out.
Okay.
Retail is brutal.
I like everything
about your company
except the fact that you have
a product that's in retail.
You're still vulnerable
to every new product
that comes in
trying to teach
robotics/programming/whatever
to girls.
I'm out.
Herjavec: So, Daymond,
you're at $200,000 for 30%?
Yeah.
Is there any wiggle room
in the...
You know,
the challenge is...
Let's just talk
industry standard.
A normal licensing agent is
normally around 25% to 35%.
They don't pay you anything.
They just get it
and go represent it.
I'm paying you $200,000
to go out and license it.
Make him a counteroffer, Sharmi.
What's your downside?
Would you come back with 20%?
You won't regret it.
We will do a great job for you.
I am so dedicated to this.
I‐I'm planning
on the licensing part.
I'm gonna have to stay
at 30%.
You know...
25%?
We're meeting ‐‐
For $200,000?
Yes, yeah. And it's so far ‐‐
The idea is for us
to go and license it.
Yes, it is.
You got a deal.
‐Yeah!
‐Yay!
Thank you so much.
‐Congratulations, Sharmi.
‐Yay!
Thank you.
You sold it!
‐Well done, kids.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Congratulations.
‐Bye‐bye.
‐Thank you.
A deal with Daymond means
that we've got
a fantastic
licensing opportunity,
and that allows us
to get all girls coding.
He knows the toy business, and
we could do so much together,
and this is great.
I mean, I can't believe
I got a deal. Yay!
♪♪